hello believe nation I started the
mentor me series to try the hanger on
people who've done a lot more than us
and hopefully by spending a little more
time with them
some of their mindsets and attitudes and
work ethic seeps in the eyes to help us
become the best version of ourselves so
today we're going to learn from Michael
Jordan on staying motivated mentor me
Michael
goes back to Michael Jordan
Michael Jordan my own expectations are
just to go in and try to contribute you
know and don't try to do anything out of
the ordinary
and I was all by myself so it was time
for creation I do a record where I go
again good or great competition I enjoy
that big makes me become a better
basketball player
dribble now to Jordan Michael leave for
the left side jammed it right over
Rollins here's Michael at the foul line
I really said understanding it's just
normal but then you have to step it up
another level to be above
everyone saying that it's going Leo
can't be NBA champion I never believed
maybe it's my own fault
maybe I led you to believe it was easy
when it wasn't maybe I made you think my
highlight started at the free-throw line
and not in the gym
maybe I made you think that every shot I
took was a game-winner if my game was
built on flash and not fired
maybe it's my fault that you didn't see
them failure gave me strength that my
pain was my motivation
if I led you to believe that basketball
was a god-given gift and not something I
work for every single day of my life
maybe I destroyed the game
oh maybe you just make an excuses a
shocking revelation tonight for all
Chicagoans bull star Michael Jordan will
announce his retirement tomorrow
achieved practically everything I could
from an individual standpoint and from a
team standpoint and it really made it
easy to walk away why he was on top what
I ever unretired I don't know baby
laughs people may think is off-the-wall
maybe it is the right size we let me
know if they feel that I'm not
Michael Jordan is returning he released
a press release today that said quote
I'm back at the time - I retired you
have been eating food now I got
something
are you as good now as you were when you
left I'm better
the champions of the world
an emotional moment for a Michael Jordan
it's not about two shoes
it's about knowing where you going not
forgetting where you started it's about
having the courage to fail
not breaking when you're broken
taking everything you've been given and
making something better
it's about work
before door
and what's inside of you
doing what they say you can
is not about the shoes
it's about beans we were born to be if
you put your mind to doing whatever you
want to do you know good things can
happen that I could be better than what
people think and I can you know surpass
any expectations that I may have for
myself I'm a firm believer that if we
have good game your game is gonna say
that yeah you don't have to say it so I
guess it's trying to play down some of
the trash-talking you know an animosity
that's between in words and and a whole
promotional thing let your game be your
promotion your marketing tool this whole
thing about your you practicing I mean
if you talk any of your teammates they
would say even if they saw something in
a game is like shoot you shoulda saw him
Thursday the practice with you was like
like they had a game instead of a
practice and when I got to the pros with
Kevin Locker II you know when I was
drafted number three Kevin Locke he used
to put me on the starting five
we used to be killing the second five
but he wanted to test me out so we can
be let's say we're going to eight and it
could be five to one four five to two
against the second team if you lose you
gotta run he would switch me in the
middle of the game to the second thing
I'm saying well okay he trying to fool a
point boom we have bounced back and wind
again those are all training tools for
me and every day in practice was like
that to me it was a competition so when
the game come there's nothing that I
haven't already practiced it's a routine
you know whatever happens in the game
now okay I've done this before
sure was fear failure a motivator ah and
that if I never feared about my skills
you know because I put in the work put
me where Jake work ethic eliminates fear
yes you know so if you put forth to hurt
to work then what are you fearing you
know you what you capable doing what
you're not
six rings from scoring 25 MVPs
all-defense nine times they'll even
appeal to a month ago downtown one word
to sum up your period
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of the video what was the
best clip what was a single best clip
that got you the most motivated I'm
really curious to find out please leave
in the comments below I'm gonna join in
the discussion thank you again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon